David magno is on radio island in
Beaufort North Carolina he's at a hotel
that has just sustained some damage
there David we saw you earlier and still
you're having a hard time standing up
right Gail we're at the Yacht Club
on radio Island Road in Beaufort North
Carolina there's some scaffolding you
can probably see in the shot and that
bad boy hadn't even moved
despite wind gusts of up to 90 miles an
hour where we are right now that fence
is laying down pretty hard behind me an
Old Glory they are flapping in the wind
god bless her
is holding on I'm gonna tell you the
water is rocket as you can imagine I'm
standing I got one foot in the pool
holding on look the power is out in
Beaufort
there's about 14,000 people who live
here they've been told is essentially
shelter and this in place at this point
there's a mandatory evacuation order
that's been a no effect since dusk it
expires at dawn but listen there's no
way anybody's going to be able to get
out on the road right now the storm
surge where we are hit about seven feet
now remember storm surge is when the
water from the ocean gets pushed on land
by the wind right so seven feet and
they've also had the highest water level
reported here in Beaufort just within
the last 12 hours
we're told that these wind gusts will
continue at this rate sustained right
around 70 miles per hour for another six
to eight hours we're on the north east
side of hurricane so as Florence is
making landfall right now and some
people are experiencing the silence but
quiet of the high we are experiencing
what is perhaps known as the worst of
the storm that northeastern quadrant and
we're standing in it right now
David Beck now taking shelter in a
swimming pool you can't make this up but
you see the ferociousness of this storm
and how widespread it is throughout both
states right now in particular in North
Carolina David thank you